[Music]
[Boys are playing basketball, shouting and running.]
[A whistle blows.]
[A boy on the sidelines with braces on his legs retrieves a stray basketball and throws it back on court.]
[Narrator:] The  chances are you've never seen this boy before,
but you've seen many like him.
His name is Harris, Johnny Harris,
and he's in the seventh grade at District
Two.
Though Johnny himself is a stranger to you,
the disease that made him a cripple is no stranger.
It was poliomyelitis, a communicable disease.
[Music]
Encephalitis,
Rocky Mountain Spotted Fever,
ringworm,
infectious diarrhea,
murine typhus,
malaria,
influenza.
Communicable diseases: where do they come
from and how do they spread?
Many diseases like tuberculosis, poliomyelitis,
and influenza survive in man,
and they're spread from person to person.
Some diseases spread by other means:
Rats may carry typhus.
Mice may cause bacillary dysentery.
Mosquitoes bring malaria, dengue, encephalitis.
Ticks bring Rocky Mountain fever, relapsing
fever.
Flies carry typhoid, trachoma.
Fleas carry bubonic plague.
Some diseases spread from contaminated meat
or food.
Raw milk may cause diphtheria, undulant fever.
Polluted water: schistosomiasis, cholera.
[Music]
[An ambulance pulls up at the hospital and a person on a stretcher is taken out.]
Every year hundreds of thousands of people
suffer from communicable diseases,
and many die unnecessarily from preventable
infections.
Communicable diseases recognize no boundaries,
for they've taken their toll of human life
the world over.
Their control may be a national problem
or it may be regional, involving several states,
or it may be local.
An epidemic might start anywhere and reach
into many states.
The classic example is the 1918 influenza
pandemic,
which was first recognized in Boston,
and within a month spread throughout the entire
country.
Today, always watchful for epidemics,
practicing physicians constitute the first
line of defense,
but the responsibility for the prevention
of communicable diseases
is vested primarily in the state and local
health departments,
which are assisted upon request by the United
States Public Health Service.
[Speaker sitting at desk:] The Communicable Disease Center, with its headquarters in Atlanta, Georgia,
serves the nation in field investigation,
prevention, and control of communicable diseases.
In cooperation with local health agencies
all over the country,
the Communicable Disease Center, better known
as CDC,
has established diagnostic laboratories, applied
research projects,
control operations, and field training centers.
CDC employs a variety of professional specialists
skilled in every aspect of communicable diseases.
[Narrator:] Medical epidemiologists,
veterinary epidemiologists,
public health nurses,
laboratory technicians,
parasitologists,
entomologists,
sanitary engineers,
statisticians,
training specialists,
and many others who work together to solve
the practical problems
and get results in the fight against communicable
diseases.
It may be a problem concerning a section of
the country
where year in and year out its rivers rise
to flood out whole towns and villages.
The flood subsides, leaving in its wake billions
upon billions of mosquito larvae,
and the threat of malaria becomes obvious
once more.
Scientific information on the subject is discussed
and analyzed,
decisions are made, and one of these is to
design more effective equipment
to combat the dreaded mosquito.
Ground equipment or air equipment,
inexpensive to build, cheap to operate,
but effective, and its effectiveness
will depend on many factors,
all very familiar to the engineering mind.
The type of larvicide best suited to the problem
and how many gallons per minute will the unit
deliver.
How large the nozzle, how wide the orifice,
how much pressure for maximum effect?
Field test: how well does it perform under
actual conditions,
gallons per acre, distribution,
widths of the swath,
size of the droplets.
So, it's the job of CDC to develop, experimentally,
procedures, materials, equipment
and to test them until their effectiveness
is established beyond question.
The proven techniques are then demonstrated
to the state health authorities,
whose personnel are trained to carry out the
programs.
[Speaker sitting at desk:] In common with
medical organizations all over the world,
CDC is trying to solve the riddle of poliomyelitis,
which kills or paralyzes thousands of people
every year.
[A young girl is making her way across the grass using crutches.]
[Narrator:] In the research laboratories,
it has been found
that where flies have access to the feces
of infected persons,
the presence of the virus of poliomyelitis
can be demonstrated in the flies
by injection into susceptible animals.
But are flies an important and frequent mode
of transmission?
Would fly control reduce the incidence of
poliomyelitis?
[Speaker at desk:] We know now that flies
do transmit another disease
which is a very real public health problem,
dysentery.
Today, CDC has organized with state and local
health departments
a nationwide fly-control program
to reduce the incidence of dysentery.
Yet, at one time flies were only suspected
as carriers.
[Narrator:] It has since been demonstrated
that clinging flies
exposed to a culture of dysentery organisms
carry these germs in or on their bodies.
If the fly remained on the culture for only
a few seconds
and was then placed on a sterile medium,
the medium showed colonies of dysentery organisms
after a period of incubation.
It was found that the same sort of transfer
occurred
when flies went from feces to food.
Because these scientific observations strongly
indicated
a probable relationship between dysentery
and flies,
the development of an experimental program
was decided upon.
In this case,
it was undertaken jointly by the National
Institutes of Health and CDC.
As the first step in the program,
epidemiologists selected an insanitary section
of town,
a section that was known to have a high incidence
of dysentery
and where it was also known that there were
many flies.
Flies would be controlled in one-half of the section,
but not in the other.
But to prove that flies were important carriers,
it would have to be shown that the morbidity
and mortality rates
of the controlled area had been appreciably
reduced.
For this experimental control program,
special tools and equipment were designed.
[Men are shown building and assembling equipment.]
[Music]
Fly populations were measured, identified
and collected
for laboratory studies throughout the controlled and uncontrolled areas.
[Music]
[Fly collection activities are shown.]
Schoolchildren from both areas were brought to the clinic.
Rectal swabs were made so that bacteriologists
could determine the presence of shigella organisms.
[Music]
Epidemiologists determined the amounts of diarrheal morbidity by going
from house to house through both areas asking housewives
if members of their families had experienced
diarrhea in the last 30 days.
Mortality figures were obtained from the county
health officer.
In the area to be controlled, inspections
were made to find the fly-breeding areas.
[Music]
Fly-breeding areas were brought under control
by basic sanitation procedures.
[Music]
This experimental program proved that dysentery
could be reduced from one-third to one-half
by fly control.
[Music]
[A report is being typed.]
[Speaker sitting at desk:] When we knew that
dysentery could be reduced by fly control,
and the expenditure of public funds was justified,
the next step was to demonstrate to the states
the proven operational procedures,
and train their personnel in the application
of these practices.
Such arrangements are usually made through
CDC regional representatives
when requests for assistance comes from state
health officers.
[State Health Officer:] Sam, I wonder if you
people could help us.
We've got ten counties in this state
where the death and sickness from dysentery,
especially babies,
have always been higher than the rest of the state.
[Sam:] Yeah, I know most of those counties
are in the low-income areas,
no garbage disposal, bad sanitation, in fact
everything's bad.
[State Health Officer:] Yes.
[The state office stands up and walks over to the window.]
You know we've always wanted to get some fly
control going down there,
but we just haven't had anybody that knows
how to organize the program
and see that it's carried out.
We don't have any equipment: trucks, bulldozers,
draglines, sprayers.
[Sam:] We can send you some big power sprayers,
but we haven't the money for trucks and draglines
and things like that right now.
We may be able to give you a little more help
later on.
In the meantime, could you work out a deal
with your highway department
to use some of their heavy equipment?
[State Health Officer:] I think we ought to
be able to work something out there.
Now, about that training course in fly control
in Atlanta next week...
I can't spare any of my people right now,
and it will be a couple of months before I
can get anybody to Atlanta,
and we want to get this thing going.
[Sam:] Since you're going to have a big program,
it might be more economical to start the training
program
right here in your state.
I'll see what I can do with the Atlanta people.
[State Health Officer:] Oh, that's fine, Sam.
Now, we've got some more training problems.
What are we going to do about all of those
technicians
that require all the special courses?
Now, you've just got to help me, that's all.
[Narrator:] So CDC trained the personnel of
this state
on the proven methods of fly control,
and enabled them to set up their own program.
Training is an important part of the CDC organization
and covers such things as water supply,
stream pollution,
sewage,
housing,
laboratory procedures,
sanitary engineering,
mycotic diseases,
and many others.
Training centers are strategically located
throughout the United States
and are attended by state and local health
personnel
and students from many foreign countries.
Audiovisual aids for training are planned
and produced by CDC.
[Knobs on a film projector are adjusted.]
All types of printed material are also available.
Training at all levels is carried on in the
diagnosis,
prevention, and control of communicable diseases.
CDC is one of the task forces of the Public
Health Service,
a reservoir of engineering, scientific, and
medical knowledge
ready to help each state in its fight against
communicable diseases.
Today, as yesterday, the challenge continues,
and opportunity is great for doctors, for
nurses, for scientists,
and for many others with the ambition
and with the training to accept that challenge.
[Music]